hello and thank you for spending your
time with us today
we'll cover two new selective sensitive
and effective techniques for dealing
with two of the most troubling problems
we all face today in the environmental
world the analysis of microplastics and
surface waters with ted gcms and
measuring perfluorinated alkyl
substances in outdoor and indoor air
using thermal absorption gc msms
so we'll get right to it
first we'll talk about the analysis of
microplastics
so what are microplastics well there's
no exact definition there is a reference
document put together by iso that
references the approximate size
there are primary microplastics which
are microplastics that were built that
way as small pieces of plastic and there
are secondary microplastics which are
created by degradation of larger pieces
of plastic
these plastics can be thermoplastics
thermosets but also elastomers
water is usually in the matrix someplace
and there's a number of analytical
methods that could be used so let's talk
about how this what we're trying to find
out
there is no catch-all analysis for
microplastics there's number of things
you want to know like particle number
and particle size the morphology of the
particles the state of degradation or
oxidation
but more importantly we'd really like to
get to the polymer ids and the mass
balances because these are important
mass balance and polar
and id and polymer id can potentially
identify the source of
microplastic
so this is an overview of the many
different methods used to characterize
math
microplastics uh this isn't currently in
an iso draft method
cd24187 we're going to focus it first on
paralysis gcms because it's really good
at looking at mass balance it's one way
to get at that so paralysis gcm sms is
close
but the samples are small in mass
between 100 micrograms and 10 milligrams
with about one milligram being pretty
typical they're small in size less than
a square millimeter and if you're using
filters to collect samples from water
several punches must be taken to the
filter
consequently this results in needing to
take many samples to get a
representative result
so to deal with this shortcoming thermal
extraction absorption gcms was developed
as another way to get mass balance
and get around the problems of getting a
larger representative
so
therma automated the ded gcms is the
thermal extraction and paralysis of
larger samples offline in tga followed
by mass balance determination via
evolved gas analysis and tdg cms
so to give an idea how this works
so you would take a water sample on a
through a filter crucible for example
you would take a surface water sample
you collect the micro plastics that get
caught in this crucible filter
this is very nice because there's no
punching or cutting of paper filters
needed now and this is suitable to go
straight into the tga
so once we have our filter sample either
in a filter crucible or we have perhaps
there may be a soil sample we want to
put into a ceramic crucible
it could be any kind of environmental
sample sediment soil filter paper etc
and in ted now our size is much larger
we can deal with samples as large as 100
milligrams effectively
we carry out paralysis of this sample
inside the inside the furnace of the tga
this typically is between 300 and 600
degrees more towards the 600 side all
this is done in an inert gas flow this
causes the polymer to decompose and fall
apart into fragments that are
identifiable
these fragments as it when it decomposes
are collected uh they say pass by a
gruesome twister this is made of pdms
polymethyl saloxane
once these
compounds been collected by the twister
the mps auto sampler picks this up and
runs it automatically cms
so let's talk about that process briefly
once inserted into the thermal absorber
thermal absorption occurs
followed by marker compound
identification so if you're looking at
polypropylene polyethylene and
polystyrene for example we're looking
for
marker compounds that tell us which one
of these co which one of these polymers
we're originally dealing with
software identifies those or
or rules them out and then they're
quantified consequently
so this is an example of some of the
some of the things we can do with ted um
this is eight different kinds of
polymers polyethylene polypropylene
uh polystyrene polyethylene terethalate
and several others um what we're trying
to do here again we're trying to look
for marker compounds that are particular
to the polymer um this allows us to
identify the polymer and we're also
going to use several other compounds as
uh let's guess ions
so this is an example of polyethylene as
a way of doing this um we get great
correlation between spike mass
polyethylene and peak area typical for
polyethylene marker substances
so
note that the use of four unique marker
compounds make the data much more
reliable so we're looking at four
different peaks here identify poly
identify polyethylene all four must be
present
all four are dienes are
one in terminal dienes so
the only way these are going to be
present is the polyethylenes there
marker compounds are created during
paralysis and they don't exist naturally
in the sample that's making it very
unlikely to have a false positive
so this is an example of looking at
microplastics from street drainage here
styrene butadiene rubber was identified
from tire wear ends up being around four
to ten percent by mass of the sample
entirely
notice that most of this is actually in
the smallest size fraction these were
taken these samples are taken in several
different filters to have different
sizes
most of this is out in the sludge but
there's significance amount of svr in
every part of the sample so
now in terms of street drainage
sbr from tires is significant contribute
this is another example this is polymer
mixture done with paralysis gcms in in
comparison to ted gcms
this is the same size sample in each
case and you can see really quickly that
on the paralysis
and pyrolysis graph we get data but we
don't get enough of it the t gives us
much more information
so if you want to learn more about this
in much more detail there's several
journal articles out here i'd recommend
particularly the jay chrome a article uh
by dum chen eisentrout celina and braum
um very good paper actually they're all
very good papers but more information
can be found here
um we'd like to thank actually the
people who created the technique uh at
baum erica brown eric domchin
uh paul eisentrout it's in the remainder
of the group um along with folks in our
and digital like kleine bennett juan sal
joe jackie white cabbage and jack stuff
uh and laura bernelli for their
development of this technique as well
uh if you have any questions please
contact us
um and for now we'd like to jump on to
the topic
looking at
the
ways to look at people performing today
substances in outdoor and indoor air
using thermal extraction gcm
sms so what are what is pfas or
perfluoroalkylated substances
um
there are general comp several compound
classes perfluoroalkyl carboxylic acids
or pfcas most common one that gets the
most that it gets the most press is pfoa
or perfluorookanoic acid
there's also perfluoroalkane sulfonates
p phos pfos now this is this is also the
second most commonly discussed
is not amenable to being done by gcms
unfortunately and then there's another
compound referred to as gen x that's
it's trade name it's a pifo a
replacement
rather than give you the long chemical
name for it that's the structure
and then there's telomeres so these are
these are usually breakdown components
of these larger compounds
a telomere to make a telomere take x
regular carbons for example uh and
finish with all all perforinated so as
an example the f8 tube for fluorotellum
or alcohol
is eight fluorinated carbons are fully
fluorinated plus two normal carbons one
of which has the oh sitting on at the
end so it's actually ten carbons overall
so eight two is eight fluorinated
carbons two regular carbons and then the
functionalities occur at the end
normal carbons are always next to
functional group whether we're talking
about an alcohol and acrylate or
anything else
and there's all kinds of bits and pieces
um there's degradance of all of these
telomeres and larger compounds there's
substitutions
to get around various patents and other
things companies would put a chlorine
here or an iodine there
um
consequently because of all those
substitutions we get a lot of different
variations and currently epa is looking
at over 6000 known species and that list
is growing daily
so it's a pretty diverse set of
compounds it's not any one thing it's
it's looking at a large number of things
but definitely um
there's a there's a target class there
are several target classes we want to
focus which we'll get to in a moment
why do you want to use thermal
absorption gcms for indoor air
as a way of looking at this
um for air analysis thermal absorption
has a lot of advantages concentration we
can take 100 liters of air and we can we
can concentrate it down to a microliter
gas injection into the gc
this gives us access to small volatile
perfluorinated degradants that are hard
to see by the lcms methods used for this
in drinking water
we get a wide coverage of vvocs very
volatile compounds to svocs semivolatile
compounds we also get neutral and ionic
pfas as well like gen x
and we can do low flow pumping this way
which allows us to do long sampling
times which is
which results in large volume time
weighted sampling there are some risks
however um
for the lightest compounds it's
difficult or not possible because we
can't really trap cs4 or c2f6
um large volumes of air
potentially large water load for the
gcms because large volumes of air have
significant humidity and humidity
significant amounts of water
so large volumes can also potentially
overload the system resulting in
carryover or system cleanout if too much
is brought on and of course as i
mentioned earlier we can't do sulfonates
so how does thermal absorption work
well in thermal absorption
we pick a tube that's appropriate for
the analysis in this case a tube that
works for pfas
this is an example of what a tube might
look like there's a this is a glass tube
that has sorbents inside
that tube is connected to an air pump
so we can see in this picture in this
case actually we're going to hook up
three tubes at the same time here
into these cases
and we can take three samples
simultaneously
the pump has started at a known time air
is pulled through the tube at a new and
calibrated flow rate in a desired time
the total sample the the pump is turned
off i mean thus we know the fixed volume
of air that we've sampled
these pumps now gotten very
sophisticated they record the start and
stop time in the calculated volume all
for you it's very very easy to do
so that the tubes are then capped and
carried off and brought to the
laboratory so what happens there
so in the lab
they're analyzed by two-stage thermal
absorption
and in the first stage we put a
transport adapter on top of this tube
and an auto sampler places that tube
into a thermal absorber where it's leak
checked heat and flow are applied and
this can be done in a split or
split-less matte fashion this is an
example of a tube that's being has been
loaded into a gerstrol td 3.5 plus
thermal absorber if you could see inside
the td that's what you'd see inside is
the tube sitting on top of the focusing
trap
so that's all done valveless
the focusing traps necessary because we
need to use a high flow to get things
off that td tube but we need a
relatively low flow over gcms so we we
blow things off the tube and recapture
them on this focusing trap
where they're gathered for later
injection that's done simply by
reheating that trap in this case very
rapidly with flow and the analytes pass
directly on the head of the column this
also can be done either split or split
less
now one interesting thing about this
gersol's been involved since the early
1990s and thermal absorption and every
system we've built it's always been free
of teflon
so we never really had an interest in
that was wasn't we never had a need to
use teflon but as it turns out now pfas
that's very important because teflon in
the sample pathway can result in loss or
gain of perfluorinated compound
so let's talk about how to build a
relatively easy pfas method
now that's kind of killing with kindness
if you're an analytical chemist you know
that there is no uh easy method to
eating method development all these
methods take a long time to method to
build and validate but we've done this
at gersol and we have a very nicely done
validated uh pfast method
so we choose a sorbent that we want to
use for pfas um
i could go into that in detail i don't
have enough time today to go through
that but in short that resulted in the
custom set assortments that are we call
now the gerstil pfast tube
um we you need to use a column in a gc
that's appropriate for pfas
we got around to that that was an
interesting process you'd think that
these compounds who have molecular
weights in the 500 range would be
something you run on a db1 or db5
no it turns out that even because of all
that fluorine they end up being pretty
volatile and the 624 column is needed to
do that
and then you need to look at the mass
spec so how we going to do this so we're
going to stick with the normal sim scan
method on the single quad
we need to use a high res instrument the
tandem msms a triple quad and then we
once we did once we get to that you
would build an ms method around that um
just for now
let's go ahead and just look at what
this looks like on a single quad
what happens if you do this analysis in
a relatively quote unquote clean office
environment
so we did that getting this is where
that slide came from previously um we
you know we took this we took some
samples in an office environment steady
temperature and relative humidity um we
use those pfas tubes i mentioned we ran
for 40 mils a minute for 24 hours this
ends up being almost 60 liters of air
sampled we did this in triplicate so
we'd have three replicates there we also
had an unspike tube that uh was not run
that would that set by that that's set
alone
all these tubes were spiked with pfas
before they were run that was done on
purpose because we
we needed to see we have to assume that
there's no pvas in the room assume
there's no latent concentrations
but we spiked the tubes to simulate the
exposure as if there were and of course
you run an unspike tube by comparison
and we'll have some idea of knowing what
really is in the room and again there's
no teflon in the sampling train none of
the sample pathway all the little white
pieces you see there in that picture
these actually these little white pieces
are actually
polyethylene high density polyethylene
they're not teflon at all so there's no
there's no teflon in the sample train
so this is an example one of one of the
spike standards um this is the
fluorotelomer acrylate
this is the most behaved out of out of
all these and we'll call it the good
nice high mass results in a pretty much
flawless background nothing else nearby
the 518 amu there's not too much
floating around that you'd pick up
except the actual analog we're looking
for
unfortunately this is the only ones the
518 ends up being the molecular ion for
this and it's the only one that had a
strong molecular ion all the other ones
fell apart
but high mass equals low noise low risk
of interference low low positive low
risk of false positives the low noise of
course is going to be great detection
limits
unfortunately that was again the only
one that behaved well
looking at the
uh
mifosa which is one of one of several
compounds we looked at did we look at a
total of about 14 different compound
classes um in this case the most
dominant ion for mufosa ends up being
94.
so this is sim done on 94. we did three
other fragments for verification but the
point being here you can see that as the
mass gets lower we end with a lot more
noise that that noise is
bad because it's going to end up
resulting in risk higher risk of false
positives
and also lower deter higher detection
limits because of all the noise that's
there
so you've seen the good and the bad
now let's talk about the ugly
the fluorotellum or alcohol eight eight
two ftoh
um this is sim at mass 31. now if you're
an experienced mass spectrometrist
you're asking why would you do mass 31
in this case it's because you have very
little choice it's the strongest ion
that this ftoh produces you want to try
to use it for cover quantitation
but you have to ask especially here now
you see the spiked versus unspiked tube
well is it real or is it matrix
so you don't know is you have a high
risk of false positives now at this low
mass and this is this is a consequence
and this is a real problem for
fluorotome or alcohol this particularly
for this compound which is
it's very much of interest to epa and
others for groundwater contamination and
vapor intrusion in the basements and
other things so
this is going to be a challenge
so low mass equals high noise and high
high risk of false positives
so the limitations of render using is
there's simulations of using a single
quad
in sim mode for pfas and indoor air
the mz-31 fragment's not ideal it's the
most abundant though there are other
ions but they're even smaller in
abundance
um although better than 31 into z the
other ions are also low in mass
and of course any of these alcohols will
never give you molecular ion to begin
with an electron impact based ion source
if you take all of that and you add to a
near continuum low mass background that
comes from this huge amount of air
that's sampled you have a recipe for
matrix interference and false positives
so
and pretty much every with the exception
of ftac which you saw previously all of
these compounds fall into this
predominantly low mass ion trap
so we end up having this issue there is
a way to deal with it
this is kind of a spoiler alert this is
the same for nanogram spike of ftoh but
or not or in this case pfoa but now done
on msms with the triple quad
so note now i'm sorry this is ftoh note
now we're using an mrm using an mrm
transition of 131 to 65 and we virtually
eliminated the
noise and background so
we end up building a method um
we found a sorbent that worked we found
a column that worked and
in the end sim scans okay but 10 mm sms
is far better for large volume air
sampling for indoor air or outdoor air
if you're also doing large volume air
sampling due to the high matrix at such
a large volume sample
so the use of msms will greatly reduce
the background for all of these analytes
spoiler alert actually down in the
single digit part per quadrillion in
some cases
so really grateful in the pfas work for
uh the help of dr jack stuff and jackie
white cavalier gerstel who did all this
work i'm just fortunate enough to be
able to talk about it today
the work was inspired by heidi hayes at
eurofens
who helped figure out a lot of the
issues behind sorbent selection and also
what classes of compounds we should be
looking at
jesse miller at camsco helped us
get a hold of those tubes help to create
those tubes that are specific to this
analysis i also want to thank drew
anamal and tim congelico at agilent for
their encouragement and particularly for
the support using the triple quad for
this work and several colleagues at
uscpa who were also behind this and gave
some ideas and support and encouragement
for getting this done
um
especially for what to look for where
and why that's still an ongoing question
six thousand compounds and growing and
we're still trying to understand where
they all are
so and of course thanks to all of you
thanks for listening today
hope this was great i hope you had a
chance to learn today
if you have any questions please reach
out my email address is here along with
my my linkedin address please be able to
reach out to me either ready to replace
keep an eye out on link keep an eye on
us at linkedin and on versatile us for
new developments in the pfas method and
also in microplastics
and of course there's a lot of great
content on what we're doing on youtube
both in terms of the science and what
we're doing but also
basic things like how the instrument
works and how to maintain it etc
thanks again i appreciate all your time
and i hope you have a wonderful day